[Music]
kurt uh let's get started you know what
was it like seeing your life dramatized
on the big screen with such incredible
actors like zack and anna where we're
playing you and your wife brenda well i
mean it's obviously surreal uh you know
you hear people talk about it for years
oh your story is made for the big screen
but to actually see it come to pass see
some incredible actors actresses you've
got an unbelievable cast but there's a
lot of emotions that come with it
obviously you're excited you're excited
to be able to use your journey to
hopefully inspire and encourage other
people but it also brings some anxiety
and some nervousness that you want the
story to be done right you want people
to be connected to the story and anytime
you put that stuff out there there's all
those emotions that come with it how
involved then were you in the filmmaking
process i was actually really involved
everything from the script being able to
write the script and kind of shape the
script to brendon myself being on set
and giving input on different things and
again it's always hard to let go of your
story things that you know are really
connected to you but there's times you
got to step back and trust the people
that understand that world and
understand the movie that they're trying
to make and then there were other times
that they allowed us to come in and have
input and do things that i believe made
the movie better
you